let's talk about the rule of law and
having a civilized country with
processes that are adhered to in line
with the framework of our country that
includes co-equal branches of government
and distribution of powers the Trump
administration has already ignored they
are past due on eight impeachment
subpoenas now there are far more than
eight impeachment inquiry related
subpoenas that have been issued the due
dates on some of those have not yet
passed it's October 22nd however and
I've been talking about this what good
is a Constitution what good is the law
what good is a constitutionally
enshrined impeachment process if the
Trump administration can simply ignore
it but not only ignore it get away with
it which is exactly what is going on the
answer is all of that infrastructure all
of those duly enshrined powers of the
co-equal branches of government
they are pretty damn worthless if they
are not going to be enforced and it's
not just Democrats it's also the
judiciary that is a part and parcel of
this so let's look at them okay some of
these are document requests Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo was supposed to turn
over documents about Ukraine 17 days ago
he hasn't done it there's no
consequences
Gordon sunland the US ambassador to the
European Union a major Trump donor he is
seven days overdue on a subpoena for
documents consequences none Rudy
Giuliani or Giuliani as some people like
to say Trump's personal lawyer maybe
it's not clear Trump claims not to know
whether Rudy is still his lawyer
supposed to turn over a ton of documents
hasn't related to Ukraine he's in the
thick of it possibly criminal six days
past mark Esper the Secretary of Defense
he is six days overdue on a subpoena for
documents Russell Vaught the acting
director of the Office of Management and
Budget is in deeply with regard to
Ukraine it's been six days since his
subpoena was do-nothing lev par ness and
igor Froman these are the henchmen these
are like Nixon's Watergate henchmen
these are Associates of Rudy Julie
Jonnie who are five days overdue on
request for documents subpoenas they
were caught literally fleeing the
country on one way playing two plane
tickets heading to the airport and
arrested Mick Mulvaney Donald Trump's
acting chief of staff three days past
due on legal subpoena document requests
and of course Rick Perry Trump's now
resigned Secretary of Energy a much
bigger player than we originally thought
in the Ukraine fiasco he is also several
days past due on subpoenas when you're a
regular person when you forget to comply
with a subpoena when you opted not to
comply with a subpoena it has
consequences whether it's a court
subpoena or a congressional subpoena I
know that there are Republicans playing
the stupid game of well listen you know
Court subpoenas are one thing but
congressional subpoenas they don't
really have that full force number one
you're wrong number two the Trump
administration and associates have also
ignored court subpoenas so if indeed
they are two different things they've
been treating them the exact same way
when you are a normal person ignoring
subpoenas has consequences it doesn't go
away you get arrested you're held in
contempt it's bad but so far no
consequences exactly as I suggested to
you would be the case so part of this is
the system hasn't really had to deal
with this degree of flouting of the law
what I mean by that is there are not
past presidencies we are not looking
back at past presidencies through
rose-colored glasses it is merely a fact
that past presidencies unless you really
go back to Nixon have not a clouded law
in the way that the Trump administration
is doing and to a degree as legal
scholars have pointed out the system as
it was designed never presumed that you
would see a presidential administration
flout the law to this degree that is one
part of the problem but Democrats are
also part of the problem it is time for
law enforcement to get involved in
enforcing these subpoenas it is time for
Congress to actually demand the full
enforcement of these subpoenas
and they're not doing it and there's
plenty of blame to go around it is not
just one party or entity that is guilty
here and the sickest irony of it all
it's that if and when Democrats did
start enforcing these subpoenas with
force they would be called
authoritarians they would be accused of
using men with guns to enforce political
grievances they'd be accused of listen
you're putting people in jail you are
the authoritarians and it would be
another one of these acts of blatant
projection it would be one of the most
authoritarian white houses that we have
seen in a really really long time
the pot calling the kettle black what do
you think if you're watching on YouTube
leave a reply if you're not if you're
listening to the podcast or watching on
free speech TV or anywhere else send me
a tweet at D Pakman what do you think it
will take if anything and the answer may
be there will not be there is nothing
even hypothetically that will do it for
Democrats to start demanding the
enforcement of these subpoenas we will
take a quick break and be back after
this with much more including if you
want to talk about authoritarianism the
way this administration has dealt with
the media is at the top of the list and
Donald Trump now telling his bedtime
phone buddy Sean Hannity from Fox News
that he is going to be terminating the
press rights at the White House of just
so happens to be the New York Times and
The Washington Post we'll talk about
that after the break